still wondering why so many girls are
single let me give you an example so my
best friend and I went out over the
weekend for her birthday and she was
talking to this guy from one of the
dating apps I think hinge so she's a
really sweet girl and not really into
being mean but I'm a bad [ __ ] and I
don't let men walk all over women
so let me first just give you a little
bit of background she has never met this
man before and they've probably only
been talking maybe three or four days so
he was talking to her about meeting us
out on the night out um Tobias drinks
and to get to know her while she's
around her friends so it was a little
less awkward so he texts her maybe 15
minutes later after telling her he was
going to meet us out and is like
actually I'm not just I'm just not
feeling too well could you actually come
to my place right now I bought us a
bottle of wine and she was like um no
like this is weird I'm out with my
friends like why is he being like that
so I was like okay give me the phone let
me text him and I text him back and I
said I'm just not the type of girl to
just come over and [ __ ] on the first
date I'm more of a wine and dine type of
girl and he said I know that I said then
whine and dine me first LOL and he said
I didn't even think you were spending
the night I legit thought you were just
enjoying a glass of wine just to talk
and stuff okay then why wait until
another night so I said I told you I was
going out with my friends thought you
were meeting us guess another time then
and he said I just had hectic week I
wanted to spend the night in his all I
was going to come over to high Banks but
you didn't text me that you were out
even though she definitely did so anyway
I just liked the message and I was like
okay let's just make it the end of that
but we can't do that with men obviously
so he texts back and says I now see why
you're 25 and single and liked his own
message then continues to send all of
these messages you can pause the read
but really they all say the same thing
and then even more
it even says like hell I'll show up in
10 where are you at so I can come out
wait what and then ended it with just
have a good night I hope it's fun she
has never met this man before and he
sent her 30 messages
are you okay does that sound okay this
is stocky Behavior this is weird
Behavior this is why women are still
single not because we can't get a man
but because we don't want y'all
if you're still yeah but you can't get
the men that you want so plus is is
women
um yeah but that's another episode my
question is though after that does do
dating apps make people feel entitled to
me 100 yeah
and what it does is it grants you access
to someone's attention so once you're
exchanging attention do you feel intact
to that person's attention let the video
showed he didn't know that girl from
when from anyone but for some reason he
felt entitled to drop all those messages
right
done I guarantee he took a look from his
mum no dad's teaching this son to move
like that
you're itching to say something wrong
that was just made me laugh because I
kind of agree yeah I think that over
access to people even like for me over
access in general so I don't go on my
phone too much I'm sometimes I'm more
time if sunlight don't disturb I'm not
on social media all the time if someone
sends me a message I'm well within my
right to not reply until I'm ready to
talk to the person and I my friends
people that know me know that that's how
I move so they're not offended but
because people we've in this generation
where we are giving instant access to
everything we're not you see if like I
want to actually talk to someone I don't
want to quickly reply while I'm in the
middle of doing something else I'd
rather wait until I have time right then
then be like rushing around and then we
that's why people are constantly in
their phones getting confused not not
interacting and that goes back to us not
interacting in person because we're
stuck having 20 different conversations
and we're not even present in the moment
that we're in so for me I think yeah
that over access and that entitlement of
you have to immediately respond or
that's the reason why when I went on
hinge I got overwhelmed and I I was on
hinge for 24 hours thought the profile
idea was cool I wasn't really in it for
myself again a friend that said look try
and go on their chat and I thought you
know what I've got nothing to lose I'll
try something new if it's not for me
it's not for me but then the messages
coming through and it was just
overwhelming for me and I was like this
is actually too much so I just canceled
it so given over access to yourself and
in terms of dating apps I've had friends
where they've been talking to a guy and
then when it's like actually I don't
want to meet you the person turns nasty
and it's like why are you turning nasty
like you're entitled to say actually not
for me and not waste a person's time but
people just take things defensively I've
had that where like because I'm on
social media people that don't know me
feel like they know me yes and so it's
like maybe they'll have seen my show or
maybe and like they'll kind of treat me
a certain way when they've never even
talked to me in real life and it's
interesting because it's like the way
they'll talk to you is like as if they
know you and I'm like I don't know who
you are
and you know what's interesting pill
right they'll send you a message
it starts off like hey how you doing I
hate it and you don't and you don't
message back and you don't even know
they've messaged you right and then the
longer and then they start getting mad
and I'm just or they call you out in the
comments for not replying to you yeah
listen message me again
and the thing is I think that
entitlement
when it comes to like social media is
one of the reasons why I you know why
I've bought this um this subject up
because when we are interacting with
people like this in general like we
don't I don't feel entitled to anybody's
attention generally if I interact with
them but social media and you know
dating apps make you actually feel
entitled if you're interested in the
person because I think we feel that way
we were not interested what happens when
you're interested in a female or a
female's interested in a guy and we all
know how often we are all on our phones
right so I feel like it's hard for
people to say you don't get irritated
and you know songs with their phone and
they choose not to remember and I think
that's something that social media has
created that that sort of anxiety online
but not for you is that yeah I'm online
but not for you is that why don't you
reply to me when I know you got your
phone next to you because you are yeah
what's that who are you if you like for
example if my mother and calls me God
knows if I don't answer she's like
what's going on she calls me again I'm
gonna answer any scenario and be like do
you see what I mean because that's my
mum so she's she can have in access to
me if it's your partner they get
Priority Access but I think it's not
anything I feel like men get turret men
get more sold territory with that and
this is one of the things I always tell
men to just chill the [ __ ] out sometimes
like
men get territorial with women that they
don't know it's so crazy that I've not
like I'm just like she's not your girl
bro because there's too many ways to see
what a person is doing because it's that
cool you can see who feeds your story
you can see when someone's online you
can see it sounds like your message so
it's like if I it's I think the
perception in a lot of guys heads is
that again there's that level of
entitlement that they're not self-aware
enough to understand that you're not
entitled to my time but then it's a case
of all right I've given you my time
whether you like it or not and then I
can see everything else we're doing
including looking at my story
do you get irritated when someone looks
at your story but they don't reply to
your message I don't care because I do
the same thing to everyone else
I'm not too fast because my thing is
this is like when your social media is
at a level where you're constantly
getting messages you switch off so like
for me if I see like three or more
messages no one's getting a reply no
until I'm ready to take it one by one
right and it's going to be like one
every other hour because I'm talking
about things and I might still post a
story I might still post content I'm
just not replying to you because I'm
doing other things so let me ask you a
question already as a man like that
because sometimes I feel like that
um comes into real life so you see if
you're in a club or a bar setting right
and
you buy a woman a drink do you feel like
she's entitled to give you her attention
for the rest of the night no right no
that's exactly why I never accept drinks
I always say it to me it's no like
because you get some blokes that think
because you've said yes then that's it
do you think do you think you should
only accept a drink if you're interested
in the guy yes yeah I could see why some
women view it like if they're offering
just take it do you see what I mean
because that's not just with men that's
just in general that but I'm not gonna
laugh he's dumb enough to buy you a
drink without exactly like any sort of
reason behind it then finesse's money
like that's another thing is but the
consequences of that if that means I've
got to spend the night avoiding him then
I don't want to do it so I'll just say
no I I agree with you I would rather
just
I just feel like you shouldn't accept
things from people you're not interested
in right I agree you know I I think like
finessing like sure you could go that
way but it's just better to avoid it's
not definitely it's better to avoid it
but I'm just thinking if the guys and
dumb enough to one of them
for me again it goes back to you
obviously what I call source and knowing
how to court and talk to a woman like
for me I'm only ever buying you a drink
if the conversation is of that nature
leading to that like I'm not gonna buy a
drink as a way to court you I think it's
I don't have an opening line exactly
they're just oh can I get you a drink if
we're having a great conversation
and you know your drinks running low and
we're still talking by all means I'll
offer you would you like a drink that's
like because we're having a great
conversation it's not a chat of lion of
mine you know what I mean so like if a
girl takes that drink I've had an
interaction that's worthy of me buying
her drinks off if she goes away for the
night I'm good because I've had a great
conversation yeah but that's it but the
thing is is like
like like Pearl was saying like this is
my advice to women don't accept drinks
from men that you're not trying that you
don't find attractive that you're not
trying to take it another place with
because you just never know like and
it's the same thing with dates I'm like
why do you want to waste your time you
only have so much free time especially
like when we're yeah like when we're
young and stuff why would you want to go
on a date with someone you're not
attracted women go on dates now with men
just to eat yeah for the experience but
that's again because they're living in
this social media in reality where
they're doing they're going on dates
with people yeah they're taking they
wanted take a picture of the meal they
want to do this and then post on socials
like they live in the High Life yes but
that's nonsense as well because it goes
on a first date and starts taking photos
of do you see what I mean but everyone's
trying to get I'm not gonna I hate when
women take pictures of photos
yeah
pictures of food it's like the food just
came you're like and there's a lot I
just want to eat
what the hell I see girls do those tick
tocks and oh my God I saw this one girl
and it was the first date and the [ __ ]
was tick-tocking it yeah she was like
putting in the video and I'm like girl
what are you doing I still think that's
on the guy though like come on like
don't listen don't let a girl get away
with that
um but you know what if I'm being real
you your Viewpoint makes sense because
at the end of the day we've got to seek
the best outcome to situations and the
best outcome to a situation where a guy
is making herself entitled to your time
it's best not to accept it for the best
outcome for yourself yes because you
will get women who do complain about oh
he didn't leave me alone all night
because he spent money on you yeah and I
equate money to time you worked for that
money which is time lost you can't you
call you can get money back but you
can't get time back 100 so if I'm giving
you that time then realistically I I
should be able to expect that you give
me time back as a result of that so
women it's just to use them so women
stop accepting drinks what about the
girls that go to men's tables then the
same thing stop go into a man's table
right
I've been in the when I when I was in
the clubs right
um I've seen women like at a man's table
like taking all the champagne all of
that kind of stuff helping themselves
today helping themselves and it's like
what at the end of the night what is
going on because that guy is speaking as
man he's thinking I'm spreading cheeks
he's thinking I've spent all this money
something's going down like what the
hell and women are literally there's so
many women out there like I'm just gonna
take his drinks don't do it
but you know I'd always be girls pretend
like it's innocent oh I was having a
good time it was just a bit of fun is
that wait what Stop Believing women man
like that I just don't under I just I
feel uncomfortable accepting drinks and
even like free anything from someone I'm
not attracted to because you got money
moscale are broke that's what
I was raking in that coin I mean girls
step out with five pounds I know no way
to get home
no but it's true like I've seen like
Street interviews and women have been
like men have said to women oh when you
go out for a night
do you pay for your own drinks we'll be
like no I don't pay for my own come on I
don't know how they're getting home
right they know they will make your home
you know what that is it is not that's
nuts and the thing is if if you have
that mentality understand that there are
men out there if you if you are going
out not knowing how you're getting home
there are men out there going out
thinking I'm gonna smash something
tonight do you know I'm like I don't
know alcohol's involved and alcoholism
it's the whole thing as many of you know
I was just banned on Tick Tock and we
are demonetized on a daily basis on this
platform if you want to help please
consider sending a super thanks below
every donation helps and it helps make
what we do possible